(playful music)
- [Narrator] This is Northwest Arkansas,
the birthplace of Walmart and
the gateway to the Ozarks,
which you've probably heard of
because of that Netflix show.
- You owe me to job?
- What?
- [Narrator] But for the most part,
this little corner of the
country is off the radar
for today's legions of remote workers
who are itching to bounce
from their high-priced,
high-density confines
in cities like San Francisco and New York.
But, here they all are.
- What?
- Are you serious?
(woman cheering)
- Duh, fantastic.
- [Narrator] Getting a Zoom call
saying that they've been selected.
- I feel like I won the lottery.
- [Narrator] To help put
Northwest Arkansas on the map.
- How soon do you think
you could relocate here?
- Wow, okay.
- [Narrator] Among the many
incentivized relocation programs
attracting remote workers
since the pandemic,
this one in Northwest
Arkansas offers $10,000
to those who move to the area
and stay for at least a year.
We're talking about
cities like Bentonville,
Rogers, and Fayetteville.
- I did see that Fayetteville
was also top places
for singles to meet people.
- [Narrator] They'll even
throw in a mountain bike.
- Geez, $10,000 and a bike.
- [Narrator] After receiving
more than 24,000 applications,
the program called their first 25 winners,
just a few weeks ago.
- I wasn't expecting you to
tell me, so now I gotta--
- Oh goodness, I'm
definitely gonna call my mom.
(Dazz laughs)
- [Narrator] It's
probably not a huge shock
that hundreds of applicants came
from the pricey tech hub of the Bay Area
and that includes the Portillo family,
Josue, his wife Athena, who both work
for tech companies and their three kids.
- Thank God.
I would looking for a sign.
I was surprised and just full of joy.
Me and my wife have been talking
about trying to get a home,
a new home for our family.
- Our living situation in San
Jose is very, very compact.
It's a two bedroom,
so all of us are in that little condo.
- [Narrator] Before the pandemic,
Josue commuted four
hours a day from San Jose
for his job in San Francisco,
leaving just a few precious
hours left to spend
with his kids at night in
their 800 square foot home,
but even though he was
able to work from home
this past year, the Portillos still dreamt
of owning a big house, the kind they still
can't afford in the Bay Area.
But now, with their $10,000 grant
and the blessing of Josue's employer,
the Portillos, which
includes Josue's parents,
say they'll be heading
to the Ozark Mountains
in a few months, where an average home
costs less than $270,000,
70% cheaper than San Jose.
- When we went to go visit Arkansas,
it felt like a different country.
It just felt like a secret
place that we found, like a gem.
- [Narrator] The Portillos
are among the growing numbers
of remote tech workers
fleeing the broader Bay Area
and especially San Francisco.
In fact, nearly 40% more people moved out
of San Francisco during
the pandemic months
compared to the same
period a year earlier,
the largest increase of any
major city in the country,
according to data from
moving company, Updater.
Most moved within California,
but these states were
also top destinations.
While cities like Austin,
Denver, and Seattle
are enticing Bay Area tech
employees more than ever before.
This comes as some of the
biggest tech companies
like Twitter, Facebook, and Salesforce,
San Francisco's largest private employer,
have all announced more
permanent remote work options.
- I just never had given
a thought to Arkansas.
- [Narrator] But if
smaller, less known places
like Northwest Arkansas wanna compete
for these remote workers,
they have to sweeten the deal,
with cash and tax incentives
in the tens of thousands.
- This is gonna be amazing.
- [Narrator] Like Tulsa, Oklahoma did.
Though it's $10,000
grants launched in 2018,
the program saw a dramatic rise
in applicants since the pandemic.
It now has more than 500 participants
living and working in Tulsa.
A newer program called Choose
Topeka pays up to $15,000
and has brought in 30
workers in just over a year.
- Right out of the gate, it exploded.
So, I mean, we had over 3,500 applications
within the first 30 days, globally.
- [Narrator] Bob Ross
runs the Topeka program.
- It really exposed a
tremendous pent up demand
for people looking for
something new and a fresh start
and they saw Topeka as
a possibility for that.
- [Narrator] Having won a
$10,000 grant from Topeka,
Tyler Jaggers moved out of the Bay Area
and bought a $47,000 house in
Topeka that he's fixing up.
- I was already thinking
about moving, pre-COVID,
and then once COVID kicked in,
coupled with things such as, myself,
I was living next to a
fire evacuation zone.
- [Narrator] As an indie
video game developer,
who often dresses up for all
the networking events in town,
Tyler hopes it will be
easier to grow his company
with the lower cost of living.
- It's a nice little sleepy town.
It's not like bustling.
There's not a ton of traffic.
If you need to park, there's a spot.
You got a big truck, there's a spot.
Got a small car, enjoy it.
So, it was just great fun.
- [Narrator] Ross sees
remote workers, like Tyler,
as an investment, one that will pay off.
- What we found is that $10,000
in remote incentives
translates into $50,000
of economic impact in just one year.
And then, you add in
just the soft benefits
of the intellectual and cultural impact
that there'll be making.
It's $10,000, very well-spent.
- [Narrator] But skeptics
of these relocation programs
say the pandemic won't
last forever and then what?
San Francisco supervisor, Matt Haney,
believes the Bay Area
will always be the home
of innovators and entrepreneurs.
- The tech industry has had
such a strong ecosystem here
that for people who wanna network,
who are starting businesses
and wanna recruit folks,
engineers, a lot of that
is concentrated here
in the Bay Area.
- [Narrator] And even if
these relocated tech workers
don't return, that doesn't mean
a new wave of talent
won't take their place.
- It may not be the same companies,
it may not be the same
people before the pandemic.
Only the biggest, richest companies
could even secure office space here
and that may change,
which I think could create
a renaissance for startups
who wanna be in San Francisco.
- [Girl] Did you saw that?
Mommy, look at that big bubble.
- [Narrator] The Portillos say
they don't expect to
return to the Bay Area.
- I think the only way we would come back
is the cost of living goes down,
but I don't know if that's gonna happen.
- [Narrator] But the
family says a fresh start
couldn't have come at a better time.
Several weeks ago, the entire
family contracted COVID.
Josue's father was on a ventilator
and they weren't sure
he was going to make it.
- When he finally came
home, it was a miracle.
The doctors say it was a miracle
and then, a few days
later we got the grant.
It just felt like that saying,
"It's always darkest before the dawn."
(Josue's father singing in Spanish)
- Josue's father is expected
to make a full recovery
and now, with some extra cash
and the promise of finding
affordable property,
Josue can live close to his
parents and look after them.
Some sort of acre lot, maybe even placing
her house and my house next
to it, having a little ranch.
(laughs)
Yeah.
(gentle music)